Digamos que tenemos el siguiente número:
905.074. ¿Cómo podemos expandirlo y qué
representa realmente esto? Pensemos en cada uno
de los valores posicionales que tenemos por aquí.
Este 9 está en la posición de las centenas,
literalmente representa 900, 9 centenas,
así que lo podemos reescribir de dos maneras
distintas: podemos reescribirlo como 900 y como
9 x 100, que es lo mismo. Ahora, este 0 representa
0 decenas, pero 0 decenas sigue siendo 0,
así que no nos tenemos que preocupar mucho
por ello, no sumaremos ningún valor a nuestra
expresión ni a nuestro número. Después tenemos
el 5, este 5 está en la posición de las unidades,
literalmente representa 5 unos, podemos
decir simplemente que representa 5; ahora,
si queremos escribirlo como 5 unidades podemos
hacerlo como 5 x 1. Hasta aquí hemos representado
al 905 como 900 + 5 o 9 x 100 + 5 x 1. Y puede ser
que digas: "Oye, ¿cómo sé si tengo que multiplicar
o sumar primero?, ¿debería ser esta suma antes que
la multiplicación?" Siempre es importante recordar
el orden de las operaciones; en este escenario
debes hacer la multiplicación antes que la suma,
así que debes multiplicar 5 x 1 y 9 x 100 antes
de sumar estas dos cosas juntas. Pero prosigamos.
Después tenemos otro 0, este 0 está en la posición
de los décimos, es decir, esta posición nos dice
el número de décimos que tenemos, pero tenemos
0 décimos así que no agregamos nada. Ahora vamos
a la posición de los centésimos: literalmente
esto representa 7 centésimos, así que podemos
escribirlo como 7 / 100 o 7 veces un centésimo;
entonces más 7 x 1 centésimo. Y por último
vayamos a la posición de los milésimos: aquí es
la posición de los milésimos: tenemos 4 milésimos,
literalmente esto representa 4 milésimos, 4
/ 1000, o 4 x 1/ 1000. Observa: esta parte
corresponde a la posición de las centenas, tenemos
0 decenas, pero escribiré decenas para poder ver
la posición, tenemos 0 decenas -por eso no nos
molestamos en escribirlo aquí abajo-; después
tenemos la posición de las unidades, tenemos 5
unidades, luego tenemos 0 décimos -por eso no
lo escribimos abajo-, siguen 7 centésimos,
7 centésimos, y 4 milésimos, 4 milésimos.
Y hemos terminado. Escribimos esta expresión
para entender lo que representa este número.